[Musique]
des barques ou ce qui a vraiment lancé
votre carrière à la sorte d'écho
nationale de théâtre c'est virginie
dufour qui déprime à cause de mon
précédent contre 1 à mi chemin pour une
fois pendant cinq ans vous savez jouer
le même rôle celui de bobby rajotte
c'est fabienne larouche qui les a fait
confiance c'est dans quelle mesure ça a
tout changé pour vous ben en fait c'est
à partir de ce moment là que j'ai
commencé à me faire reconnaître un peu
dans la rue ça fait en sorte qu'on
m'associe beaucoup au rôle de tout
croche de bain c'est ce que parti c'est
un peu c'était ma carte de visite le
faire dgo un peu rebelle dégage mal rôde
à ses vues vous avez dit se faire
accrocher dans la rue vautrot de serge
biron dans l'unité 9 aussi ouzou soins
sont aussi surpris ça c'est encore plus
quand je sors de montréal je me fais
quand même beaucoup puis même je me
rappelle d'un dalot prune bien avec mon
père dans un bar puis il ya un couple
qui est arrivé puis la fille sexy que
jamais tu es jaloux le japon lui que je
leur paye la traite pour procurer à
battre donc c'est ça c'est le
désavantage défaut de sortir quand fred
et des baumes légaux de campagne et ça
c'est ya pu avoir
je consomme pas capable de mener la voix
je consomme pour comment on vit avec
cette pression là justement surtout
après la scène du viol dans une taie 9
je veux qu'il y ait des gens qui font
peut-être pas la séparation entre le
personnage et la personne vraiment ça me
dérange pour nous mais premièrement
j'aime le monde
quand j'ai le temps je prends le temps
de leur expliquer mon contexte je suis
très très bien avec ces mots je fais ce
métier-là pour pas être ordinaire donc
quand j'ai la chance de jouer des
personnages qui mettent leur soeur d'un
truc comme ça c'est quand même très
plaisant à faire parce que ça va le
l'ombre loin dans des zones en venant
vers les extrêmes c'est ce qui
m'intéresse
vous avez joué beaucoup de rôles très
intenses recherches biron d'unités 9 le
gui qui laisse sa soeur se faire violer
flamarens mentalement ce n'est pas
évident parce qu'on est accaparée par
notre personnage d'une certaine façon où
vous pouvez faire la part des choses la
distinction là je te dirai que je vais
très bien la part des choses pour deux
raisons premièrement mon et en six jeux
très intense donc je capable d'aller
très loin dans disons et une intensité
qui vient avec une ouverture diaries et
le fait que j'ai eu accès à des zones
assez rock'n'roll dans ma vie passée
donc pour moi ça c'est pas tout ça mais
c'est en fait c'est de ce qui me
préoccupe
si avancé l'anticipation c'est après ce
cas pas de m'en sortir tout de suite là
je reviens moi même mais c'est la vie de
chaque gros tournages je dors pas
beaucoup c'est ce que ça me préoccupe
parce que je veux être sûr d'aller dans
la bonne zone
vous parlez de passirac and roll
aujourd'hui vous avez changé que vous
considérez comme très chanceux
oui mais moi je t'ai pas si rock and
roll qu'aux deux c'est plus mon frère
qui s'étaient quittés au wac mais oui je
dirais que pour vrai sincèrement je sais
que ça fait cliché même l'école
nationale de théâtre du canada un peu
m'a sauvé un petit peu la passion du
théâtre tout fait en sorte que je me
suis bien à lille parce que une période
de ma vie que je peux dès que j'étais
assez perdu surtout après m'être fait de
renvoyer du conservatoire d'art
dramatique de québec
lol il ya eu un angle de transition où
est ce que je savais pas trop quand même
en ligne donc on dit merci au terrain
ouais on diversité rend leur dis merci à
andré brassard qui le jour de ma
première évaluation internationale qui a
vu comment j'ai peut-être croche qui
j'allais pas bien il me fait comprendre
qu'ils me prenait comme j'étais puis
elle dit après ce temps fais ce que tu
veux c'est vous c'est moi ça ça a été
extrêmement marqué ma vie à mon parcours
c'est là que je suis devenu un adulte au
paradis vous venez d'avoir 40 ans que
c'est un âge transitoire pour les
comédiens ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
sais ce que c'est mais tous des coui je
trouve cette belle tradition tout
acoustique on reçoit forme physiquement
je me sens chaque j'ai beaucoup
d'expérience maintenant
et puis je me sens en pleine possession
de mes moyens je me sens mieux que
jamais une nouvelle vie pour l'instant à
votre attention s'il vous plaît et je
dis ça puis en même temps
le deux semaines je jouais l'homme
éléphant en tournée je disais non je pas
stressé à 40,1 jamais mon énergie et
cinq minutes après j'étais sur scène je
faisais mon monologue et j'ai eu un
blâme et moi parce que je me pensais
trop bon vin qu'on ne peut jamais soir
c'est bon cuba coupe merci beaucoup
merci qu'elle puise merci